- Don't you have a job
interview on Monday?
- Yeah, I do.
- Aren't you going to
straighten your hair?
- Mom, can we not, not do this today?
- Oh, my God, what kind of job do you-
- Hey, sorry I'm late, my hair
was so nappy this morning.
- Hey Jodie, you met Tracy?
- Um, no, I don't think so.
- Yeah, she's got the wild and crazy hair
I was telling you about.
- I really don't think
they're going to be hiring you
with your hair looking all wild like that.
- Ah! Do you know who
you look like? Solange.
- You know, I remember back in my day,
you know, you couldn't even walk into a-
- Oh my God, did you cut your hair?
- I love this new, like, black bohemian
hipster thing you've been
doing with your afro.
- No, no, no, no, no, Macy Gray.
- I know you're into this natural movement
and then you're all into this
radical revolutionary stuff.
- It's so trendy.
- Who do you think you are, Angela Davis?
- No, no, Foxy Cleopatra, shazam!
- So have you ever
straighten your hair before?
- Do you wash your hair?
- I think it'd look really cute on you.
- Can I touch?
- No.
- Your hair looks so different
every time I see you.
- Please?
- No.
- Can I please touch?
- Can you even get a
comb through this bush?
- Mom!
- I don't even know if
it's you half the time.
- You just, you don't look at my face?
- See, you running your hands through it
is like, messing up-
- Running? You think I'm
running my hands through this?
- It's so crazy every time.
- It's like a pillow.
- Can't even walk through
your hair, skip, nothin'.
- I want to sleep in it.
- It's confusing for me.
- Oh, hey.
- I just don't understand why
you stopped perming your hair.
- You looked so good
with your hair permed.
- I've never really been
a clementine guy before.
- That's just so unique
and exotic. It's just...
What? It's so voluminous and rich and...
- Yeah, I wouldn't. I wouldn't.
- It's just tall.
- I'd stop. I would just stop.
- Tracy, your hair is so big
and wild like a lion, you know?
♍ Nants zuwhenyeh
♍ wuzabun-na-na-na zenawoo
For even more wonderful things
subscribe to BuzzFeed Blue
Subscribe